so I speakers thank you thanks it's
really a pleasure to be here to
celebrate John's retirement and so my
story goes back to my alma mater
Berkeley so I wanted to tell a little
bit about how John and I met and got
connected I'm surprised you let me up
here to do this but here we go
all right so John I came to Berkeley
around the same time he came as a
professor in 1981 and I came as an
undergraduate in 1982 but I was not that
interested in network so I didn't
actually take any classes for John when
I was an undergraduate and we didn't
meet until I came back to Berkeley in
1989 enjoying praveen's research group
there's a few people in this picture
that make oh sorry
few people in this picture that may
still be in this room so this was all of
us slightly younger in 1989 in praveen's
group now I see there's a lot of people
here that got their degrees from
Berkeley but not everyone so just so you
know what happens when you get a PhD at
Berkeley this is the trajectory so you
start out there's a PhD preliminary
examination then there's a qualifying
examination then you write your thesis
and hopefully it's signed off on and
then you get your degree so Jean was
part of all of these locking points in
in my trajectory here so I now remember
I wasn't working on networks I was
working on communications at the
physical layer so prelim exam went fine
he gave me a kind of cool Markov problem
as I recall and he must have liked my
answer because he passed me so I was
done with prelims and then we come to
the PhD qualifying exam so this is where
you present kind of where you are in
your research and if you pass that then
you get to go off and write your thesis
so picture the day and time and place
this is from my qualifying exam it was
April 9th 1992 10:00 a.m. in the Hughes
room which still exists it has not been
torn down for to make room for something
else in Corey Hall
and my and my topic was what I've been
working on the Shannon capacity of time
varying channels and my thesis or the
the committee was Jean and Praveen and
Jim Pitman it was one of my favorite
professors of probability and so I
launched into my talk and first couple
slides go fine and then I'm getting a
little confident kind of getting on a
roll and then comes slide five I went
back and let slide 5 so here I'm talking
about the continuous time channel
capacity where you kind of decompose the
channel you need carpet and web
decomposition and and then John asks
what does this have to do with hilbert
spaces okay well the correct answer at
that time for me was I don't know what a
hilbert spaces I remember I took real
analysis as an undergraduate and so here
David Hilbert raises his head in my exam
and of course I have no idea how to
answer this question and so my vision of
getting a PhD and going on and becoming
a professor is vanishing at a very rapid
rate and it didn't come to me a Hilbert
space just for those of you that don't
remember it's a special case of a vector
space of house enorm and it's complete
so all limits limits of limits are in
the space and all that but I didn't
remember any of this now if at the time
I was it skilled at deflecting questions
that I don't have the answer to I would
have said nothing can we move on right
because that's a reasonable
any question especially if you don't
know the answer but of course I was not
skilled in deflecting questions or being
an arrogant academic and saying
something like that in a thesis defense
so I kind of stuttered and and got a
little choked up thinking that my degree
was going out the window and all this
somehow I did manage to get through the
exam and I passed so then I was moving
on to the thesis writing and and Shaun
signed off on my thesis - so did Praveen
and so there I was as a graduate you
know got my PhD and what I realized at
that point is that that made me Shaun's
academic sibling because he got his PhD
from praveen a few years before I did
and so all of these tough questions were
really just to make sure of the purity
of the lineage so that demeaned in any
way by me getting my PhD so so then I
graduated moved on and then it turned
out even though John had been working in
networking and I'd been working in
Wireless we started actually coming
closer together in terms of our research
partly because of the path program so
the path program funded my research this
was a program to create automated
basically autonomous vehicles on
highways in California this goes all the
way back to the early 1990s and John was
working on the communication
architecture and I was looking at the
wireless piece of this and so then then
I was honored to get asked by Praveen
and John to write a chapter on wireless
communication in the second edition of
their book and so I guess I somehow
convinced John that I knew something
about wireless enough to put this in in
that chapter and then even recently a
tack on three workshop there was a
session on wireless networks and lo and
behold John was one of the speakers so
of course I took the opportunity in the
middle of his talk to ask him about
hilbert spaces
and to remind everyone that payback is
hell when you give someone a hard time
on an exam so anyway
John it's really been an inspiration to
know you as a researcher I don't
appreciate everything you've done in
networking because I don't work in that
field but I know some of it and it's
it's been a wonderful journey to watch
your all of the things you've done
you're a great professor I took believe
or not information theory from Shawn
right at the very end of my time at
Berkeley I think I got an a-minus
because I was not nearly as good in some
of the math and it was but that was the
first time information theory was
offered at Berkeley and the whole time
that I'd been a student here so it was
fun to learn it from you from a
different perspective and also you've
been a wonderful friend all these years
so anyway with that I'm gonna launch
into talking about this wireless
connection and what's next for for
wireless networks note that John's talk
was about 4G networks what we're moving
on to 5g so I'm gonna talk about what's
new and exciting in in the next
generation of wireless networks so as
you've seen I've been working in
Wireless my whole career 30 years and to
me it's a really exciting time to be in
Wireless maybe the most exciting time
because in the past working in Wireless
was really about either people talking
to other people over wireless
connections or accessing information
over the Internet
and now we have so many more ways that
we want to use Wireless whether it's in
sensor networks or in devices inside our
bodies all this automation of highways
of smart cities of the energy grid and
so there's a lot of interesting new
applications which require us to build
different types of networks and we've
had in the past one of the big
challenges is the fact that there's very
limited spectrum so this is a graph from
a couple years ago which said that as of
2013 the license spectrum which is what
the cellular phones use is 300 or is is
full and of course we've gone on since
20:13 to build more and more wireless
devices and use more and more spectrum
but we're not using it in the licensed
band we're using it over Wi-Fi on the
horizon is millimeter-wave where there's
tens of gigahertz of spectrum and one of
the new things that I'm working on is
molecular communication so why not try
to use molecules to send information so
I'm going to talk about that a little
bit at the end so if the license bans
are full now how are we going to support
the internet of things so the notion of
the Internet of Things is that every
single device with an on-off switch is
going to be able to connect to each
other and connect to the backbone
Internet and that's a very different
type of network than we've built up
until now in particular because these
devices so maybe in my tennis shoes or
in my sensor in my backyard or in my
thermostat these are devices that have
very low energy sources and they may
actually not even have a battery and
also low data rates so up until now
we've been pushing for higher and higher
data rates and now we're going to
devices that maybe need bits per second
the interesting thing to me about the
Internet of Things is that it's not so
much that it's important that my tennis
shoes talk to John's tennis shoes or I
guess not tennis shoes I what's
important is that collecting all this
data and sending it up into the cloud is
where and doing the processing in the
cloud and figuring out how to utilize
all this data that's where the value of
the Internet of Things is and so that
means we need a communication
infrastructure that can do all this for
devices that again have very limited
energy and maybe need to last the
lifetime of a building or of a car or of
a bridge and so forth so so how are we
going to build networks like this one of
the questions that I asked because I
still work in Shannon capacity is are we
at the Shannon capacity limit of
wireless systems so I'll just take a
show of hands how many people think
we're at the Shannon capacity limit of
wireless systems raise your hand how
many people think we're not
okay so you're all wrong because we
don't know the Shannon capacity of most
wireless channels and that actually goes
back to my PhD research we were looking
then at how to compute the Shannon
capacity of wireless channels and it's a
hard problem in most cases so if we
don't have a model which is the true
four millimeter wave channels we don't
have good models for that certainly not
for terahertz not for molecular channels
if we don't have a channel model you
can't compute unit capacity if the
channel is time varying even though I
got results for that in my thesis in
some special cases for most time varying
channels we don't know the capacity we
don't know the capacity with
interference or relays that's been an
open problem basically since the
beginning of Shannon theory cellular
systems have interference and so they
introduce interference so we don't know
capacity of those systems don't know
capacity of multi hoc networks and as
soon as we introduce things like delay
or energy or dollar constraints you
can't drive the probability of error to
zero which is the underlying premise of
Shannon capacity so we can't bring in
things like hardware constraints or
limited energy into solving sham Pasi so
I'd say well then why do we work in
chanock capacity if it doesn't tell us
anything interesting about designing
these systems in fact that's not true so
Shannon capacity does provide in my
experience a lot of interesting insights
into the design of wireless systems as
well as performance upper bounds so I'm
going to talk a little bit about some of
the enablers for this next generation of
networks including utilizing millimeter
wave spectrum along with massive MIMO
rethinking cellular system design
completely through a notion called
software-defined wireless networking a
little bit about new physical layer and
multiple axis techniques and then green
networks now you might say well why am I
talking about new physical layer design
physical layer it's been dead multiple
times so it was first declared dead in
1971 when they said coating was dead
then the 80s it was dead in 2014 it was
also dead but there actually is some
life in new physical layer techniques
which I'll talk about briefly okay
so what's up with millimeter wave
there's tens of gigahertz spectrum up
there so everything
commercial system today fits into the
millimeter wave bands which is why
people are starting to look at it the
problem is that when you go to these
very high frequencies path loss is
proportional to 1 over lambda squared so
you get very high path loss it's very
difficult to communicate at large
distances if you're just sending things
through an omnidirectional antenna so
what you do is you build these large
antenna arrays which can point a very
pencil-thin beam in any particular
receiver and therefore you don't have
that same kind of path loss and you can
get a strong signal at the receiver in
addition once you form these kind of
pencil-thin rays everything that we've
worked on for decades in terms of
enabling wireless communications goes
away so there's no interference because
that beam is not causing interference to
any of the other radios there's no
multipath fading because there's no
reflections that arrive at the receiver
delayed in time and phase and cause the
random changes in the received signal
strength and there's very little
attenuation because again you're
channeling all of your energy in exactly
the direction that you want to go so you
might say well great this solves all of
our problems we don't need to do any
more communication theory and the other
nice thing is you say well but that's a
very big array however when we go to
millimeter waves the antenna elements
are small so you can build these arrays
and they're not so big so I like to call
this millimeter wave mass of my mode the
dynamic duo 5g communication because
they kind of compensate for each other's
strengths and weaknesses and and so
there's a lot of excitement about
building these massive MIMO systems for
millimeter waves the problem is that in
order to form this very fine beam you
need to know the channel perfectly
between every transmit antenna and every
receive antenna and that's very hard to
do and in addition if you put an object
in between the antenna array and the
receiver this whole nice beautiful
pencil-thin beam goes away and it gets
scattered and so all of these benefits
go away so it isn't the panacea that we
would like for 5g communications but
it's certainly a piece of what's going
to be in this next
generation of systems okay so rethinking
secular system design here's another
question when was the paper that laid
out how cellular system designs are
architected or how cellular systems are
architected written which decade so
first cellular system was deployed in
the 1980s so it was before that so how
many people think it was the 1970s raise
your hand that's when Shawn came to
Berkeley okay how many people think it
was the 1960s 1950s 1940s it was the
forties it was a paper by D H ring from
eighteen T Bell Labs that laid out if
you read that paper basically lays out
exactly the architecture of cellular
systems you have a base station in the
middle of a cell the toxology uses in
the cell you do hand off this is all
written in the 1948 paper and we still
design systems the exact same way okay
of course we've advanced what we do at
the physical layer we're no longer using
analog we're using digital and all these
sophisticated techniques but the basic
architecture of cellular systems have
not changed even though we've
incorporated all these techniques so you
can think about new ways to design
cellular systems where you can have the
base stations cooperate that was
incorporated in the 3gpp standard you
can have relays you can have a mix of
small and large cells you can distribute
your antennas throughout a cell these
are all things that have been
incorporated into research and also some
experimental systems but we've never
gone back and said well maybe we should
rethink the whole architecture and if we
did that then we might be able to get
big gains either in capacity over what
we have now or perhaps in other metrics
like coverage I live off Sand Hill Road
most expensive real estate probably in
the world and every time I Drive up to
280 my cell phone call gets dropped I
mean this is a voice call this is not a
high capacity call so we still don't get
good coverage and that's going to be a
real problem if we're using these
networks to do autonomous driving
and then the energy constraints that the
internet-of-things introduced if we are
going to start worrying about supporting
devices that are running off small
batteries or collecting energy from the
Sun or from vibrations we need to focus
more on the energy consumption of the
network than on the data rates that
we're going to get so small cells is
something that certainly gives us a
boost in capacity and the reason is that
if you build an architecture so that
every cell can support say 100 users and
then you shrink the size of the cell and
you still support the same hundred users
overall your system capacity grows
exponentially so it's been known for
quite a long time that going to smaller
cells gives us higher capacity the
problem is how do you optimize all these
small cells and this gets into doing
optimization in the cloud to manage the
parameters and the resource allocation
of the different users and so this is a
notion called sawn self-organizing
networks where you just send the
parameters of the network up into the
cloud and you do some kind of
optimization and then send back the
parameters so if you do that for
cellular you could do that for all
Network so you could do that for Wi-Fi
you could do that for millimeter waves
vehicular networks and so forth and this
kind of gives rise to this notion of
software-defined wireless networks so
Nick McEwen who did you know the
OpenFlow we were graduate students
together in fact the very first
probability class I ever took as a
graduate student was with Nick so he's
coined the notion of software-defined
networks for Wired networks wireless
it's a little bit different because here
you've got a different set of resources
to allocate and the way you allocate the
resources impacts the different networks
so for example if Wi-Fi and cellular or
sharing spectrum as is the case now with
unlicensed LTE you want to manage that
spectrum between the two different
networks so if you talk about how do you
do frequence out allocation this unified
control plane can allocate frequencies
across the different networks it can
allocate different power it can decide
which network a particular application
should go over so if I have a video say
an HD video I want to go over a
millimeter
wavenet work because it has the highest
bandwidth but when I move away from that
Network I need to do a seamless handoff
to another network so this is the notion
of the software-defined network
architecture and in fact if you want to
go to the shangri-la of what this means
you say well I don't need any systems at
all I'm just going to have a bunch of
distributed antennas at different
frequencies and let the unified control
plane figure out exactly how to utilize
these antennas for the different systems
of course there's a lot of challenges in
doing this the algorithmic complexity is
one as someone who worked on frequency
allocation and second generation
networks that was a np-hard problem it's
a graph coloring problem and now things
are even harder because we have multiple
antennas and power control and small and
large cells and so forth so I call this
an NP really hard problem it's not just
np-hard but fortunately thanks to many
people here and and and colleagues
elsewhere there's a lot of advanced
optimization tools to solve these
optimization problems but one of the
things that's kind of unique to wireless
is that we don't need to look at this
just in terms of distributed
optimization or centralized optimization
so if you can't get all the information
to the cloud because of the latency or
the complexity of doing things in the
cloud you could do things fully
distribute it and that's how Wi-Fi works
generally your Wi-Fi access point is
doing optimization fully distributed but
there's this notion of fog optimization
where now you can kind of form these
small neighborhoods where you do
centralized optimization within a
neighborhood and you can scale the size
of the neighborhoods such that if it's
very small it's fully distributed
optimization if it's very large then
it's fully centralized optimization and
you can look at how the performance
changes with the scaling of the size of
the network and this is something that I
think is or a size of the neighborhood I
think it's something that's really
important for wireless network
optimization we have some work on it but
I'm not aware and maybe people are have
seen in another context of a real theory
behind looking at this fog optimization
and how much can be gained over
distributed and
how much is lost versus centralized okay
a couple other things I just want to
mention so in fact there are new
physical layer techniques in terms of
wave forms for 5g that are robust to
changing channels that are more
bandwidth and energy efficient and then
with the Internet of Things we need new
ways of doing multiple access because
chopping things up in an orthogonal
manner is not efficient when you have
these very small devices so there's kind
of a whole new set of access techniques
that we can take a look at and one of
the other things that we're doing in my
group now is machine learning now I'm
not people that know me I'm not a big
bandwagon person like if everybody's
working in machine learning I'm going to
run the other direction typically but it
turns out that machine learning is very
useful in certain aspects of
communications particularly when you
don't have a channel model so when does
machine learning work well it works well
when you don't in models in most
communication system designs we have
good models for most wireless networks
we have good models for the channel but
as we move to things like millimeter
wave and terahertz and molecular there
are no good models and it turns out that
we first applied this to a molecular
communication system we're working on
because there was no alternative when
you don't have a channel model and we
got a 10x gain in data rate by using
this for our detector to remove the
inter symbol interference so it's we've
been doing some other work on applying
machine learning and contacts where
either you don't have good channel
models or network models or you have
good models but you don't know the
parameters it's too expensive to learn
the parameters so I think that's an
interesting new marionette to look at
and so that brings me to the chemical
communication so the way I got into
chemical communication is I had a
postdoc a student the graduate student
from York University who had built a
chemical communication system there it's
an on/off keying system so you're
basically now embedding bits in
chemicals instead of electromagnetic
signals so the system that he built was
an on-off keying system with vodka okay
so one send vodka zero
don't send vodka and there's a
breathalyzer on the other end and the
problem with the brothel I
is that just like you know we're gonna
do tonight to celebrate John's
retirement you get saturated eventually
yeah I don't know if it'll be with vodka
but eventually the sensor gets saturated
and you can't communicate anymore
so so he came to my group and we started
working I thought this was a pretty cool
thing to look at because it's completely
Greenfield okay the the way that signals
propagate is chemicals it's through
diffusion so it's not Maxwell's
equations it's diffusion equations so
you don't have good channel models and
everything about designing the system is
new how do you modulate bits how do you
send them through the channel how do you
mitigate the impairments of the channel
how do you have multiple users sharing
this channel how do you do networking
this is all completely new as are the
fundamental capacity limits so it's a
very fun area to work on and we actually
have a system in our lab right now so
because the vodka was not very efficient
and only got about a half a bit per
second which you might say well that's
ridiculous but actually if you think
about using this foreign body
communication to turn on artificial
organs or to do drug delivery
adjustments half a bit per second isn't
bad we got up to an order of magnitude
above that using two chemicals so now we
use an acid and a base Windex and
vinegar basically and so Stanford report
did an article about sending text
messages using Windex and vinegar but of
course now saying the undergraduates
probably wouldn't vodkas more fun yes
but how do you cancel out the alcohol is
the problem Bloody Mary's don't work as
far as I know so anyway so so we applied
machine learning to equalize the tail of
the system response which again this is
through diffusion so it takes a long
time for the chemicals to diffuse and so
we're continuing to work on this it's a
lot of fun and the last thing I'll talk
about before wrapping up is some new
work that I started as part of the NSF
Center for science of information come
or as part of that as well where we
wanted to take our ideas of
communications and information theory
and apply them beyond communication
systems so I was thinking about well
what looks like network outside of
traditional communication system so I
thought well the brain looks like a
network I was naive
I thought it was a wireless network and
then it turns out that the way these
signals propagate through the brain are
through these neuronal chains which are
actually wired not Wireless and so we
looked at a bunch of different things to
try to understand where we could apply
our techniques to to neuroscience and
what we came up with in the end was
looking at epileptic seizures to try to
find the focal point of an elective
seizure so for patients with epilepsy
that's drug resistant the only way to
stop the seizures is to cut out the part
of the brain where the seizure starts so
you get one neuron that starts
oscillating very quickly that spreads to
surrounding neurons because they're all
connected and eventually the
oscillations spread enough so that you
have a seizure so if you can go back and
find that seizure onset zone you can
give the doctors better information
about where they should be cutting
because the way they do it now is the
doctors will implant this sensor they'll
take a look at this grid and say oh I
think this is where this this sensor is
where the the seizure onset sonja's so
we introduced an algorithm based on
directed mutual information that's
basically reverse engineering so it's
looking at these sensor data and reverse
engineering through causality back to
where the signal started where the the
seizure started the seizure on its own
and it turns out we've run this on about
20 different data sets and our algorithm
beats the doctors what I mean by that is
that the data sets they annotate where
the doctor identified this seizure once
its own our algorithm gives a smaller
zone and it matches the doctors in every
case now we haven't gone back and looked
at what we're trying to do now is say
well if our our algorithm did not match
the doctor and they did the operation
was it successful or was it not
successful because that would give us
more information about whether when we
don't agree with the doctors if if we're
more accurate or less accurate so let me
wrap up I 5g networks a lot of fun I
hope you're not going to stop working in
Wireless because we could use your
insight and ideas there's a non
going to higher data rates for better
cell phone usage but also for all these
Internet of Things devices I think the
notion of this cloud-based software to
manage Wireless and how how we can do
that optimally through you know this fog
optimization is very interesting at the
physical layer using small cells in
massive MIMO there's a lot of research
to be there done there as well and then
looking at energy efficient design so
let me just say last John can't believe
you're retiring it makes me feel really
old best wishes on your retirement thank
you for your incredible contributions to
networking and to wireless to my alma
mater Berkeley and for your inspiration
and your friendship and then this last
quote happiest person is the person who
thinks the most interesting thoughts and
we think about let's think about the
hilbert space right he's like let's look
at the simplest thing and do you see
what do you see is the role of this
let's look at the simple thing yeah you
know it's a very wonderfully insightful
comment in the following sense and let
me go back to this picture because I
think in some ways there is an analogy
here where this is kind of a very
general network and then you go to this
which is very simple right I mean it's
just you've got a bunch of antennas out
there and it removes the auspices of any
particular set of constraints like in a
hilbert space where you've got you know
it's it's a generalization of Euclidean
space so and and the problem with this
is that by removing levels of or making
the problem simpler here because now I
have no Wi-Fi or cellular I just have a
bunch of antennas it makes the problem
harder right because without those
constraints now we have to think about
certainly this optimization becomes a
lot harder and and so in some ways the
reason we as engineers design systems in
layers or as particular sets of
protocols is because it reduces the
design space down to something that we
can get our hands around when we do that
we throw out optimality it's always
better you know if you have something
more general so I think to go back to
the spirit of your question what I see
for the next wave of wireless and
networking research in general is and we
see this happening with software-defined
networks and an open flow and the work
that barefoot networks is doing is can
we throw off these constraints
that we've put on ourselves as engineers
because now we've had decades of
evolution of technology and
understanding about optimization and go
back to these problems and say let's
rethink them with all that knowledge and
maybe that will lead to a better
solution or maybe it will just make us
very frustrated because we won't come up
with the answers but I think it's a very
worthwhile endeavor
[Applause]